hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and there was today there's tons
of news today so let's get let's get
started so first off there were new
executions for shinobi and Centurion
there were two each I'll show them to
you right now and then we'll reconvene
when that's over
[Music]
so those of the executions they're super
brutal especially shinobi I did really
like shinobi's I might have to pick him
up again what those come out I'm still
waiting though on the other executions
for the 12 main characters such as
warlords legsweep if you remember that
and while bringers chokeslam kind of
thing where he kind of like chokes the
guy out and cracks his neck and kind of
throws him off just kind of like throws
him away
these were leaked about a month ago and
there still hasn't been word on them yet
so hopefully these are we're at least
before season 3 if you don't know what
I'm talking about there's a link in the
description to the video you can check
out and get all caught up and then
speaking of season 3 season 3 or season
2 round 3
speaking of seasons that is the nights
did win this season so that means the
Knights have two wins the samurai have
won and the Vikings have 0 so the
Knights are one victory away from
claiming the season two so hopefully
they can come out with a win or not
we'll just have to see but it Congrats
to the Knights from their hard-fought
victory they really did deserve it
let's continue on also the public test
should be available for pre downloads if
you're a PC player do that while you can
and also this apparently been a new bug
that's been discovered where players
have logged into their game and all of
their progress and stats have been reset
it's a pretty gamebreaking glitch but
it's very it's a very easy fix this has
been mostly happening on ps4 and a few
cases have popped up on Xbox but nothing
as of yet for PC but the devs did say
just to fix this glitch just restart the
game and comeback by quitting it and
loading it and it should be fine it
seems like a visual glitch but it's also
it can be very frightening to people
when they see oh no all my stats are
gone all the hard work that you put into
the game it just vanishes luckily though
just got to quit come back and you'll be
fine if ethics still didn't help but
there isn't exactly another way to fix
it as of yet but if I do find one I will
put it in the comments hopefully this
doesn't happen to any of you anyway if
it did best of luck to all of you and
let's hope that let's hope everything
gets sorted anyway though that's going
to be the end of the video today the dev
stream is tomorrow so look out for that
video tomorrow and I'll try to get a
review on the lawbreakers beta for the
people that want to see that and if you
don't want to watch the
video don't worry about it I still got
you guys covered on the foreign or
content for you guys to watch so don't
worry about that anyway if you did like
the video please be sure to give a like
it always lets me know that I am doing a
good job here and then subscribe for
more 400 content my most recent
foreigner upload will be popping up on
the screen now if you do want to see
that we talked about some news some
other bugs and glitches that haven't
been discovered so if you don't want to
miss that and I will see you guys
tomorrow and bye guys